The correct answer is the third choice.
What we'd really like to be able to show is that we can reduce
some known hard problem to the Diffie-Hellman problem,
and the important thing is that this would show that anyone
who can solve the Diffie-Hellman problem would also be able to solve
some problem that we already know is hard.
Showing that the problem is hard just shows that if we have a large enough
instance of it, it can't be solved with a certain amount of computational resources,
and we hope that by picking a large enough instance
we can make the work for the attacker far beyond
what any attacker could afford.
That does depend on this property, so it depends on the number of values being high.
That itself is not a useful proof of security.
What we need to know is that there's no easier way to solve the problem
than trying all the possible values.